je le voyais à la télé je me disais ça
doit être ouf et puis quand je le vois
en vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là qui arrive qu'est-ce qui va se passer
là
je vais te dire le temps qu'il se
déplace on aura fini l'émission
il y a les tatouages aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'il y a en fait c'est pas
vous c'est lui d'abord
moi je vais bien
lui mettre une claque à qui et pour
quelle raison je l'aime
[Rires]
supportable je peux pas passer c'est
comme un pays c'est beaucoup de bruit on
le voit pas exactement ça c'est vrai
c'est vrai même quand tu fais un appel
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je te mets une claque alors
je rentre à mon émission
merci
[Applaudissements]
non ça va
franchement vous faites chier
[Applaudissements]
il est grand partout à autre chose